in the coronavirus pandemic wisconsin's
governor says the president
is encouraging a super spreader event
with a scheduled rally tomorrow
in janesville wisconsin the u.s reported
more than 63 thousand new covid cases
yesterday
the largest number since mid-august
wisconsin is one of the hardest hit
states
as mola lengi reports a fall
surge of coronavirus cases has arrived
and it's taking a toll
on hospitals across the country in
wisconsin where about one in every five
coronavirus tests
is coming back positive state health
officials are warning residents to avoid
all gatherings large and small which
continue to play a role in spreading the
virus
retirement parties birthday parties baby
showers
weddings all of those things that's why
we have
been encouraging here in recent weeks
that people stay home as much as
possible
wisconsin was one of eight states to
break its single day record for new
coronavirus cases on thursday
so was ohio hospitalizations there are
up nearly
50 percent in the last two weeks and
infections are rising fast
in rural and suburban counties according
to ohio state dr
matt exline the pop-off valve for local
regional hospitals is to send patients
to the referral hospitals such as ohio
state such as cleveland clinics such as
university of cincinnati
but if all of these hospitals and all
these cases are coming at once
they won't have that pop-off valve
available colleges and universities
continue to grapple with outbreaks
the state university of new york at
oneonta announced its president had
resigned
to pursue other opportunities after more
than 700
students tested positive for covid19 the
school switched to all remote classes
for the rest of the semester
another recent spike at sacred heart
university in fairfield connecticut
forced the campus to temporarily suspend
in-person classes for some off-campus
students
now their goal is to test 50 percent of
their student body
every single week gary mcnamara is
sacred hearts director of public safety
we have found that students have been on
campus
and they don't know they have the virus
and if we don't provide the testing to
know that then we can't react to it the
quicker we react to it the quicker we
can stop the spread
we are learning more this morning about
the hospitalization of former new jersey
governor chris christie
who says he spent seven days in the icu
after contracting the coronavirus
possibly at the white house rose garden
event for judge
amy coney barrett christie says he has
recovered but also that he was wrong for
not wearing a mask at the event adding
that everyone
should take this virus very seriously
anthony yeah mola thank you